former National Security Advisor Mike
Flynn receives no jail time the stock
market takes a significant dive and we
bid a fond farewell in a Jew to Michael
avenatti I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
I know a lot of people are you know
mourning today for George HW Bush I mean
the rest of the country mourns too but I
really more in today for Michael
avenatti because I had once again made
the mistake of betting it long odds on
Michael avenatti for the 2020 nomination
and once again I learned my lesson never
bet on presidential politics we will get
to all of the latest in news in just one
second first let's talk about your
impending doom so the fact is that at
one point we will all plots and when we
do we want to make sure that our family
is taken care of because we're
responsible human beings those of us who
listen to this show and that is why you
ought to go check out policy genius most
folks don't like thinking about dying
because it's depressing and they
definitely don't like thinking about
insurance which is even more depressing
than death but you should go get life
insurance right now at policy genius
it's the easy way to get life insurance
in ten minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers to find the coverage
you need at a price you can afford from
there you can apply online the unbiased
advisors at policy genius will handle
all the red tape leaving you free to do
the things you actually enjoy and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy whether you're shopping for
disability insurance to protect your
income or homeowners insurance or auto
insurance that can help you get covered
fast if you've been intimidated or
frustrated by insurance in the past well
you can overcome that with policy
genius.com go check it out policy genius
calm to get your quotes in apply minutes
you can do the whole thing on your phone
right this very instant policy genius is
indeed the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance go check it out right now
policy genius.com get your quotes apply
in minutes make sure that your family is
taken care of policy genius.com alrighty
well I begin today with a quick note
about the honoring of George HW Bush
obviously beautiful events happening all
day today in the Capitol building this
is made a national day of mourning the
post office stops its service making it
I guess the 100th day this year that the
post office will not have service and we
stopped the stock markets the stock
markets are not operational today and
well I appreciate the national mourning
for George HW Bush I do have to note
that I do agree with Charles cook over
at National Review who suggests that as
a general matter in a republic we
probably should not do be sort of
Royalists routine where whenever
somebody dies in a non tragic fashion
it's not JFK's assassination or
Lincoln's assassination or something
that having these days where the entire
three sort of stops dead because an
elected president is given state honors
this way it's kind of monarchic in
nature it's not particularly democratic
or democratic Republican in nature
charles cook writes that today he says
irrespective of whether he was a great
man or a poor woman george HW bush was a
public employee he was not a king he was
not a pope he did not found her save or
design the republic to shut down our
civil society for a day in order to mark
his peaceful passing is to invert the
appropriate relationship between the
citizen in the state and to take it
another step toward the fetishization of
an executive branch whose role is
supposed to be more bureaucratic than
spiritual but has come of late to
resemble caesar more than to resemble
Coolidge I think that is basically right
and that is not a rip in any way in
George HW Bush who I discussed at length
yesterday and who I said yesterday was a
very good man if not a great president
so again I think that it is it is
worthwhile asking ourselves whether we
have a an accurate view of the
presidency and of the executive branch
as a whole and that is not meant again
to be any sort of rip against George HW
Bush or anyone else just remember that
all of the honors that are now being
paid to George HW Bush will in the
future be paid to President Jimmy Carter
who I think is not a good human being
the thing is kind of an execrable human
being but I guess that since the
precedent is that we're now going to do
this with every president then we are
going to do it for every president who
passes away from now on again i'm with
charles cook on this particular question
okay in real in real news and because
it's not really news that their memorial
service is going on in washington DC
today in real news the big news that
happened yesterday is the sentencing of
Mike Flynn so here is how things went
down basically Mike Flynn has been
recommended to have no jail time a
special counsel Robert Muller told a
federal court yesterday that former
Trump national security adviser Michael
Flynn has given substantial assistance
to the Russia investigation and should
not get jail time Flynn has had for 19
interviews with the special counsel and
other Justice Department offices and his
early cooperation gave prosecutors a
roadmap for the Russia investigation and
may have helped to encourage others to
cooperate according to the filing the
new details explaining how Flynn has
helped the Special Counsel investigation
will ratchet up the pressure on
President Donald Trump according to CNN
who has repeatedly attacked the molar
probe as a witch-hunt okay so what
exactly happened in the Muller filing
about Michael Flynn well according to
Muller is filing Flynn has been helping
investigators longer and on
or Justice Department probes than had
previously been known the sheer amount
of redacted text in the filing should
suggest those details are not ready to
be unveiled signaling that Muller's
investigation continues along with other
investigations with which Flynn helped
and if you actually take a look at the
sentencing memo that came down and and
the Muller filing an enormous amounts of
Texas redacted meaning that it's been
blacked out so it's not visible to
public scrutiny supposedly the rationale
for this is that Muller does not want to
give clues to potential defendants as to
what he is doing at this point
Flynn began cooperating with the Russia
probe shortly after Muller scheme
approached him said prosecutors and that
early cooperation boosted investigators
understanding of what happened during
the campaign Flynn pled guilty to lying
to federal investigators on December 1st
2017 becoming the first high-ranking
Trump advisor to agree to formally
cooperate with the special counsels
probe according to the memo his early
cooperation was particularly valuable
because he was one of the few people
with long-term and firsthand insight
regarding events and issues under
investigation
additionally the defendants decision to
plead guilty and cooperate likely
affected the decisions of related
firsthand witnesses to be forthcoming
with the special counsels office and
cooperate according to prosecutors so
basically they're saying that because
they got Flynn first other people
decided that they were going to cave as
well and talk to the Muller
investigation now we still don't know
what exactly Mike Flynn has told the
Muller investigation and recall that the
charges against Mike Flynn were at the
what were very weak to begin with they
were very weak to begin with in fact the
way that the charges against Mike Flynn
were originally put forward they the way
that these charges were originally put
forward on the basis of a Logan Act
investigation so for folks who don't
remember exactly why Mike Flynn was
originally prosecuted why he was
originally investigated basically the
suggestion was that Mike Flynn after
being appointed national security
advisor elect right Trump had not yet
taken office he was talking with the
Russian government about a variety of
issues and then he lied to the to the
investigation the FBI investigation
about whom he had talked to and this
became an ancillary crime now it is not
a crime for the incoming national
security adviser to talk with the
Russian government and for all the talk
about oh well it's a Logan Act violation
he's operating his own foreign policy if
that's the case then we
to prosecute John Kerry for talking with
the Iranians while Trump is president
and operating his own foreign policy
there has not been a Logan Act violation
that has been successfully prosecuted in
a century or more in the United States
this is an act that probably is
unconstitutional in the first place
in any case the attempt to get Michael
Flynn from the beginning was deeply
flawed Byron York points this out today
over at the Washington Examiner he says
Michael Flynn has been waiting for more
than a year to be sentenced the retired
three-star army general who spent 24
days as the Trump White House national
security adviser pled guilty on December
1st 2017 to line two the FBI in the
Trump Russia investigation and agreed to
cooperate with Special Counsel Robert
Muller Flynn sentencing which has been
delayed a number of times for reasons
that have never been disclosed is
scheduled to finally take place on
December 18th last Tuesday
late Tuesday rather Muller filed what
it's called a sentencing report setting
Flynn's substantial assistance to the
investigation
Mulla recommended a sentence at the low
end of the guideline range including a
sentence that does not impose a period
of cooperation but the sentencing
recommendation did not address was the
sketchy beginnings of the flynn
investigation says byron york was
correct it started with the Obama
administration's unhappiness that Flynn
during the transition as the incoming
national security adviser had phone
conversations with Russia's then
ambassador to the United States Army kis
lyac because kis lahic was under
American surveillance US intelligence
and law enforcement agencies had
recordings and transcripts of the calls
in which Flynn and kis lyac discussed
the sanctions President Obama had just
imposed on Russia in retaliation for its
2016 election interference there was
nothing wrong with the incoming national
security adviser talking to a foreign
ambassador during a transition there's
nothing wrong with discussing the
sanctions but some officials in the
Obama DOJ decided Flynn might have
violated Logan Act which under which no
one has ever been prosecuted which
prohibits private citizens from acting
on behalf of the United States
government the Obama officials said they
were also concerned by reports that
Flynn in a conversation with Vice
President Mike Pence had denied
discussing sanctions this they felt made
somehow expose Flynn to Russian
blackmail so Obama appointees atop the
Justice Department sent FBI agents to
the White House to interview Flynn who
was ultimately charged with lying in
that interview originally the FBI did
not think that Flynn lied in March 2017
James Comey then the FBI director told
the House Intelligence Committee that
two FBI agents who questioned Flynn did
not detect any deception during the
interview and
nothing that indicated to them that
Flynn knew he was lying to them and then
Comey said the same thing in front of
the Senate Judiciary Committee FBI
number two Andrew McCabe told the house
the same thing only later after Comey
was fired and Muller began his
investigation was Flynn accused of lying
and he ultimately pled guilty so this
does lend a lot of credence and
credibility to the idea that the Moller
investigation was basically intent on
flipping people and they were going to
apply pressure in whatever fashion they
could in order to make that happen the
sentencing memo talks about how Flynn
his cooperation has been substantial but
again we don't know what that
cooperation looks like because the
cooperation itself is under wraps
basically good so the filing says that
Flynn's had for 19 interviews with the
Special Counsel and the DOJ during the
Russia investigation portions of the
memo were redacted according to Ryan
Saavedra over at the Daily wire because
it contains sensitive information about
ongoing investigations the filing states
that when the FBI interviewed Flynn on
January 24th 2017 about his interactions
with the Russian ambassador the
defendant falsely stated he did not ask
the Russian ambassador to refrain from
escalating the situation in response to
the sanctions and falsely disclaimed any
memory of his subsequent conversation
with the ambassador in which the
Ambassador said that Russia had acceded
to the defendants request now there is
part of this where Flynn is a little bit
more guilty supposedly that part is
where Flynn was dealing with the Turkish
government so according to the DOJ on
March 7th 2017 the defendant may
materially false statements in multiple
documents that he filed pursuant in
pursuant to the foreign agents
Registration Act pertaining to a project
he and his company had performed for the
principal benefit of the Republic of
Turkey the ferret filings omitted the
material fact that officials from the
Republic of Turkey provided supervision
and direction over the turkey project
NBC News is all over that they say that
basically Flynn was a tool of Turkey the
document specifically state that a key
components of Flynn's worked for turkey
involved the government's efforts to
remove from the US a Turkish cleric
living in Pennsylvania turkish president
received type erawan who is a fascist
accuses the cleric Fethullah Gulen of
orchestrating a failed coup against him
in July 2016
Flynn began working for Turkey about a
month later according to federal
prosecutors they say that Flynn's
decision not to disclose he was aiding
the Turkish government impeded the
ability of the public to learn about the
Republic of turkeys after
to influence public opinion about the
failed coup including its efforts to
effectuate the removal of a person
legally residing in the United States
again these were very weak charges they
were brought against Flynn specifically
based on lying to the FBI which is well
a crime an ancillary crime to the
underlying crime the documents say the
defendants business relationship with
the Republic of Turkey was thus exactly
the type of information fara was
designed to ensure was within the public
sphere the filing cited Flynn's false
statement that he had written an op-ed
on election day favorable to err
talansky of guellen-- at his own
initiative so the idea here is that he
had created a great sim but all of this
is ancillary to the big question which
is what has Flynn told Muller and we're
going to talk about that in just one
second and what's ahead in the Muller
investigation first let's talk about how
you can keep your home safe so I am
somebody who is deeply concerned about
home security especially after watching
the situation with Antipa members going
to Tucker Carlson's house I'm somebody
who cares a lot about home security and
that's why I rely on ring today over a
million people use the amazing ring
video doorbell to help protect their
home ring knows that very often somebody
will ring your doorbell to see whether
you're home or not and then rob your
house and this is why they have a video
doorbell that allows you to see who
exactly is at your front door you can
notify the authorities you can act as
though your home ring knows home
security begins at the front door but
doesn't end there so now they are
extending that same level of security to
the rest of your home with the ring
floodlight cam just like rings amazing
doorbell floodlight cameras a
motion-activated camera and floodlight
it connects right to your phone with HD
video and two-way audio it lets you know
the moment anyone steps on your property
you can see and speak to visitors you
can even set off an alarm right from
your phone with rings floodlight CamLAN
things go bump in the night you'll
immediately know what it is whether
you're home or away the ring floodlight
cam lets you keep an eye on your home
from anywhere that flood like ham is the
ultimate in in home security with high
visibility flood lights a powerful HD
camera that puts security in your hands
have up to one hundred and fifty bucks
off a ring of security kit when you go
to ring.com
slash Ben that is ring.com slash Ben
again ring comm slash Ben use that slash
pen to save up to one hundred and fifty
bucks off the ring of security kit and
make your home safer again that's ring
comm slash Ben for the special deal all
right so what exactly has Flynn told
Muller at this point the answer is we
simply don't know and people are
speculating
people are speculating because it says
that he's been helping in three ongoing
investigations including one criminal
investigation that we supposedly don't
know anything about yet
maybe that has to do with Donald Trump
maybe it doesn't have to do with Donald
Trump suffice it to say that nothing in
the Flynn sentencing recommendation
points to any further evidence of Trump
Russia collusion in the 2016 election
alone more damaging is a letter that was
sent by Roger stone to the Senate
Judiciary Committee this week so Roger
stone obviously has been accused is a
Trump friend and and kind of a dirty
politics guy Roger stone was supposedly
the cutout for WikiLeaks funneling
information to the Trump campaign maybe
back and forth is the accusation by the
left
well his attorney grant Smith sent a
letter to Dianne Feinstein the ranking
minority member on the Senate Judiciary
Committee saying that stone is going to
plead the fifth the letter says on the
advice of counsel mr. stone will not
produce the documents requested by you
and your capacity as ranking minority
member of the Judiciary Committee the
requests as previously stated to staff
are far too over broad far too
overreaching far too wide-ranging both
in their all-embracing list of persons
to whom the request could relate with
whom mr. stone has communicated over the
past three years and the documents
concerning imposition of the requests
for the additional reasons set forth
below
mr. stone respectfully declines to
produce any documents and declines the
invitation for an interview and they
talk about the fact that stone had
already testified before the House
Intelligence Committee and stone had
requested that if any testimony were to
be given it would be held in public
session because they don't want any
leaks and that is not exactly what is
happening here at the Senate Judiciary
Committee wants to talk to him behind
closed doors they say that this is this
is an invocation of the Fifth Amendment
privilege and it must be understood by
all to be the assertion of a
constitutional right by an innocent
citizen who denounces secrecy so it's
not that he's trying to hide anything
according to stone is that he doesn't
want the Democrats selectively leaking
what he tells them behind closed doors
this is still going to be painted by
members of the left as Roger stone
refusing to speak on these issues at the
behest of President Trump and they're
going to try to paint this as
obstruction it's hard to paint something
as obstruction when you don't actually
have evidence that Roger stone did
anything bad yet so that will all
determine on what Muller comes forth
with in the future suffice it to say
that people who are jumping to
conclusions at this point have no basis
for those conclusions you're seeing
people on the right like representative
mark Meadows who I like from South
Carolina say that the Flynn memo is good
news for president Trump here's what he
had to say there is no
suggestion that Michael Flynn had
anything to do with collusion he was
with the transition team he was part of
the campaign and yet there's no mention
of collusion I think it's good news for
president Trump tonight that this is
what has come down to even though they
said he's substantially cooperated
I think he's substantially cooperated to
say that there was no collusion and then
meanwhile you got Jeffrey Toobin over at
CNN providing exactly the opposite
analysis which is that this is bad news
for Trump the flynn sensing memo as we
think about how Muller is going to
characterize what went on in the Trump
White House the fact that he is saying
senior government leaders should be held
to the highest standards I would be a
little nervous if I were the people
involved in the obstruction of justice
investigation so the bottom line is this
is once again just another Rorschach
test
there's no evidence either way as to
whether this is going to be bad for
Trump or good for Trump or whatever now
people are jumping to the conclusion
that best fits their preconceived
notions of how this is going to go I am
perfectly happy to wait until the full
Mullen report comes out and then we see
what this is going to be if I had to
hazard a guess as to what this is going
to be as I have now been saying for
months and months and months and months
I think what is going to come out is a
lot of bad political behavior by the
Trump campaign nothing criminal but
enough in terms of ancillary crime for
the Democrats to try an impeachment
proceeding against President Trump which
by the way I'm not actually sure would
benefit them I mean this is what's
interesting if you actually look at
impeachment proceedings in the past if
you look at the impeachment proceedings
that were about to be initiated against
Richard Nixon for example they're
happening during his second term she had
a lame-duck president and there was no
real blow back to the impeachment
proceedings he never had to worry about
the actual blowback in terms of the
crowd rallying around that president so
it was a lot safer the same thing was
true of Bill Clinton right Bill Clinton
why not get rid of him he's in his
second term
but for Democrats it's possible that the
best strategy they have here is to not
impeach President Trump that instead
what they do is they just fulminate for
the next two years about how President
Trump is deeply corrupt but there's a
Senate that won't allow an impeachment
proceeding against him and so the final
revenge of the American public must be
had at the ballot box and it seems to me
a smarter political strategy for
Democrats maybe the worst thing for
Democrats here actually is just enough
material that their base demands an
impeachment but not enough material to
rally
America around an impeachment effort on
the basis of a bunch of falsely
connected dots that don't actually have
enough evidentiary basis to support the
idea that Trump should no longer be
President of the United States well
meanwhile in other news the market just
took a massive dive yesterday and ended
up dumping nearly 800 points amid rising
fears of an economic slowdown according
to CNBC stocks fell sharply on Tuesday
and the biggest decline since the
October rout as investors worried about
a bond market phenomenon signaling a
possible economic slowdown lingering
worries about us-china trade also added
to jitters on Wall Street the Dow Jones
Industrial Average fell 799 points or
3.1 percent it closed at 25,000 posted
its worst day since October 10th at the
low of the day the Dow had fallen over
800 points the S&P 500 also declined 3.2
percent mirroring that to climb the
Nasdaq Composite dropped 3.8 percent to
close back in correction territory at 71
58.4 3 the yield on the 3-year Treasury
note surpassed its five-year counter
point on Monday this is called yield
curve inversion this is never a good
sign
basically there's something called the
yield curve but the yield curve means is
the interest rate yields are usually
higher on long-term bonds than they are
on short-term bonds because if you are
take it in terms of a bond buyer okay or
a lender let's take in from a bank if
you're a bank and you're lending out for
a longer period of time that is a longer
period of time you can't lend to
somebody else usually a longer-term note
is going to have a higher yield meaning
that they're gonna have a higher
interest rate on a 30-year note then
they're going to have on a short-term
yield because again they're only
foregoing the money for a certain amount
of time this is true particularly in the
government bonds industry in which the
short term bonds have a lower interest
rate yield than the long-term bonds have
but if people are very uncertain that
over the long term they're gonna get
their bonds paid back then you have
yield curve inversion if they think the
economy is going to take a dive then
they would rather invest in short in the
short term they'd rather invest in short
term bonds that pay off in big ways in
the next six months than they would
invest in a long term bond that pays off
in ten years and so that's a yield curve
inversion it's usually an indicator that
people are seriously worried about an
economic recession again this is this is
what CMU she talks about when they say
the flattening yield curve causing
Esther's to bail on bank stocks and
concern that the phenomenon may hurt
their lending margins right because
banks tend to mirror the bond rates and
so it is possible that banks are not
gonna be able to lend at the same rates
they were able to lend at before none of
this is good for the economy and that is
exacerbated yesterday by President Trump
and his policies on trade we'll get to
that in just one second and then I want
to get to the Democratic 2020
candidacies which are heating up and
simultaneously cooling down but first
let's talk about preparing for disaster
every time you put money in a 401 K or
an IRA or you put jumper cables in your
vehicle or you purchase health insurance
you are prepping right you are preparing
for the possibility or eventualities of
something bad happening to you which all
makes sense and the same goes for
building a food storage plan the
government suggests that in case of
natural disaster you're supposed to have
a certain amount of food and a certain
amount of water on hand and you should I
mean we just saw this massive earthquake
over in Alaska I live in California
where everybody is worried about the big
one and the fact is that we do have an
emergency food supply at my house you
should too the best way to prepare is
with my Patriot supply right now they
are offering their lowest price of the
year on two popular emergency food kits
go to my special website prepare with
been calm to see them both and order
these food kits include breakfast
lunches and dinners that last up to 25
years in storage so you buy it you stick
it in the closet you forget about it and
then God forbid a disaster strikes
you're ready to go when other people
aren't preparing with my Patriot supply
is indeed the smart thing to do so go
check them out right now and prepare
with been calm that's prepared with
Ben's icon they are offering their
lowest price of the year on two popular
emergency food kits and now's a great
time to do this prepare with Ben's out
time go check it out
prepare with then.com okay so the stock
market took his major dump and one of
the reasons that it took this major dump
is because President Trump was signaling
yesterday that he was the tariff man he
tweeted out the negotiations with China
have already started a mus extended they
will end 90 days from the date of our
wonderful and very warm dinner with
President Xi in Argentina bobwhite
Heiser will be working closely with
Steve minuchin Larry Kudlow Wilbur Ross
and Peter Navarro on seeing whether or
not a real deal with China is actually
possible if it is we'll get it done
China is supposed to start buying
agricultural product and more
immediately President Xi and I want this
deal to happen and it probably will but
if not remember I am a tariffs man
capital T
em tariff man tariff man doing whatever
a tariff can when people or countries
come in to raid the great wealth of our
nation I want them to pay for the
privilege of doing so trade is not
actually a raid on the wealth of our
nation and when I go and shop at the
grocery store the grocery store is not
raiding me he says it will always be the
best way to max out our economic power
so tariffs are the best way of maxing
out our economic power has worked
awesome in the past when it basically
exacerbated the Great Depression and led
to a global depression we are right now
taking in billions in tariffs we took in
7.1 billion dollars total in tariffs
that pays for a cup of coffee on the
federal level we spend about 7.1 billion
dollars every millisecond in Washington
DC then he says in all capital letters
make America rich again tariffs do not
make you rich there so not if you
refrain from trading with people who
have a comparative advantage over you
you are poorer not richer go try to grow
your own materials for a sandwich it
will cost you $1000 or you could go to a
restaurant and buy one for five bucks it
turns out that trade a mutually
beneficial trade are the basis of any
functioning economy a president Trump is
freaking out the market and it ain't
smart he tweeted out he tweeted out this
morning about how he's optimistic at the
old we'll get them but whipsawing
between I want a deal I don't want to
deal tariffs are great tears artha like
none of this is good for the long-term
security of the market what people want
in the market is a certain level of
predictability unpredictability in the
market is a bad thing you actually want
a consistent level of regulation you
want a consistent level of Taxation you
don't want policy bouncing around like a
yo-yo because when it does I don't know
what to put my money in the market do
you right now do you feel secure putting
your money in the stock market I mean
maybe maybe not I don't know nobody
really has a clue at this point and
that's because you don't know what
policies are gonna come down the pike
any moment now all of this is also being
exacerbated by the fact that politically
speaking we don't know what the hell is
coming down the pike in 2020 president
Trump has been extraordinarily business
friendly in terms of regulation and tax
policy but all of that could change in
2020 the Democrats are obviously getting
ready and and the Democrats have put
their
finger on what they think is the real
problem they think that the real problem
is the Democrats are too smart for the
American public now I remember when they
said this about Al Gore in 2000s oh he
was just he was too wonky that's what
happened George W Bush spoke to the
heart of the American people but Al Gore
he was just too intelligent it's amazing
when Republicans lose it's because
they're too mean to vicious to cruel and
too stupid when Democrats lose it's
because they're too wonky too
intelligent too brilliant too nuanced
weird how that happens I think is mazie
Hirono who is one of the worst senators
in America is senator from Hawaii she
says that the real reason that Democrats
lost in 2016 is because they have a hard
time connecting with voters hearts
Democrats have a really hard time is
connecting to people's hearts instead of
here we're really good at shoving out
all the information that touch people
here but not here and I have been saying
it all of our Senate Democratic retreats
that we need to speak to the heart not
in a manipulative way not in a way that
it brings forth everybody's fears and
resentments but truly to speak to the
heart so that people know that we're
actually on their side okay the truth is
the Democrats have speaking much more
emotional language than Republicans on a
regular basis and so the only real
question is whether that is going to
work or not now one of the things that
Democrats do in trying to speak to the
heart is they pander like nobody's
business there's a study that we talked
about on the show last week suggesting
that for 30 years 40 years Democratic
presidential politicians have talked
down to black audiences specifically an
attempt to reach for the heart and this
is a form of the soft bigotry of low
expectations you're seeing this from the
most calculated Democratic politicians
so I think the most hilarious example of
this is Kirsten Gillibrand who is the
most mechanical politician since Hillary
Clinton I mean she is just she is a
robot with a face Kirsten Gillibrand
used to be used to be somewhat pro-life
she used to be somewhat pro-gun now she
is running a radical campaign trying to
be Hillary Clinton and trying to out
intersectionality Kamala Harris good
luck with that
here's what she tweeted yesterday or she
which is it's an amazing thing to tweet
honestly it's like when you when you're
when you're polling guru has not had a
talk with you yet but you decide that
you have
really put your finger on the pulse of
America so senator Gillibrand tweeted
out our future is female intersectional
powered by our belief in one another and
we're just getting started my god woman
do you really think that this is good
politics first of all you think
intersectionality pulls great the only
people who care about intersectionality
are a bunch of rich white losers who go
to mainstream colleges and who are not
going to vote for you anyway because you
are a rich white woman right they're
gonna vote for somebody who is not white
they're going to vote for somebody who
is a member of the intersectional
coalition who ranks higher than you so I
love that Kirsten Gillibrand is trying
to pander to the intersectional
coalition when she's not intersectional
enough for the coalition also I am so
annoyed by Democrats who do this routine
our future is female like what the hell
does that mean what I generally don't
know what that means I mean I thought
our future was going to be people who
are good at things if like if I said our
future is male then everybody on the
Left would suggest that what I was
suggesting was The Handmaid's Tale so
when she says our future is female is
that what she's suggesting that men are
gonna be chained up for purposes of
reproduction
first of all sounds great second of all
what like I don't know where this is
going and then I love you put that tweet
back up for a second I love her her
final line there powered by our belief
in one another Wow
just like windmills powered by unicorn
farts ah powered by our belief you know
what it's gonna be the future is a
go-kart driven by a woman which means it
will crash more often and powered by our
belief and one another powered by
sunshine and sparkles and powered by
hugs I can't believe that I never
thought that our future would be female
intersectional and powered by hugs
sounds amazing and she says it and we're
just getting started I don't even know
what just means what exactly does this
mean also it is mutually exclusive to
suggest that our future is female ie not
male intersectional ie not white and
powered by our belief in one another you
don't believe in males or white people
so there's that it's it's just amazing
stuff she's so mechanical it's really
hilarious and this is part of the
problem for a lot of Democrats
authenticity is still a quality that
matters in American politics for all of
his flaws president Trump dudes
authentic he can't claim that President
Trump is not authentic and if you say
he's in
santak he's authentically inauthentic
and that hair authentically and
authentic like all of these things
alright he's he is a real human
that's what's so astonishing about
Donald Trump is that he is such a real
human right but for the Democrats
there's a market lack of authenticity
and it's going to come out in the
election which is why I've always said I
think that the the best shot that
Democrats have in 2020 would be somebody
like Joe Biden who's authentically
stupid who's authentically Uncle Joe Joe
Uncle Joe by the way said yesterday that
he may be a gaffe machine but at least
he's honest the man lost his 1988
presidential race because he was outed
for plagiarism Joe Biden is a congenital
liar he lies it this is a man in 2012
who said that Mitt Romney was going to
re-enslave black people and he's
suddenly gonna be your standard for
lying and truth I remember in 2012 when
he debated Paul Ryan and he suggested
that the United States had thrown the
French out of Lebanon or something it
was like what that what he's making up
history now but yes he is authentic he's
authentically Joe Biden and I can only
get to some more of the Democratic hands
and it's on the other side in just one
second first let's talk about those
hideous window coverings that you have
in your house I know you're looking
around your house you said look I just
repainted diving furniture why just play
still look so dingy well it's because
you went down but the person before you
probably didn't do it the person who
lived there before you went down to the
local trailer park and rated the
trailers for the blinds and now you've
been living with those terrible blinds
that look like you're gonna peak between
them like a scene from et in 1983
instead you should have window coverings
that actually look nice and the way you
can do that is by going to blinds com1
SATCOM makes everything really easy for
you not sure what you want or even where
to start with blinds calm you get a free
online design consultation you just send
them pictures of your house and they
send back custom recommendations from a
professional for what will work with
your color scheme furniture and specific
rooms they will even send you free
samples to make sure everything looks as
good in person as it does online every
single order gets free shipping and this
is the best part if you accidentally
miss measure or you pick the wrong color
if you screw up lines comm will remake
your blinds for free they've made it
really easy for you so there's no excuse
to leave those mangled blinds up you
know the blinds that make your place
look like a set from the wire for
limited time get 20% off everything at
blinds command use promo code Ben that's
blinds.com promo code Ben for 20% off
everything that's full would blind
cellular shades roller shades and more
komm promo code ben rules and
restrictions to apply great service
blinds.com promo club and making place
look great instead of like the piece of
crap it looks like right now blinds.com
promo code ben okay before we go any
further and i have much much more to
talk about with you then you'll have to
go and subscribe over at daily wire comm
get the rest of the show live get the
rest of michael Knowles's terrible show
live get andrew Clavin still alive as
well get Matt Walsh's show live all of
these wonderful draws shall be yours for
the mere price of $9.99 per month and
for $99 you get this the very greatest
and beverage vessels view it cast your
eyes upon it and weep for you have no
more world's to conquer go check it out
right now for $99 ear it's incredible
also you get to be part of our mailbag
when you subscribe you get access to the
final question on our Sunday special
this week's sunday special features
David Limbaugh David Limbaugh I want to
encourage you to tune in this week to
the Ben Shapiro show the Sunday special
he was gracious enough to interview me
and we talked about my book jesus is
risen we talk about Trump and
Christianity church and state
the founding fathers and whether they
were Christian I think we have a good
wholesome discussion at least been
contributed very well I was sitting here
listening so go check that out as well
by the way before we part I want to if
you're on Facebook if you're a
subscriber we don't have to part at all
so but but if I do want to note and I
want to thank everybody who listens to
the podcast
according to iTunes this year we were
the ninth most listen to podcast of all
podcasts on planet earth so thank you
all for listening I think that's how I
think they ranked it what's great is
that if those if those are actually our
rankings and you read them linearly then
it goes us and then positive America so
I do have to kind of enjoy that thank
you so much for listening it really
means the world to us that you engage
with us every day go check out the rest
of our contents at daily wire.com and
join the club because it's a lot of fun
and we have so many awesome things
coming up next year including two more
hours of the show that you can only get
as a subscriber or if you're listening
live on radio in some major markets but
you can't listen on demand unless you
subscribe to go over to daily wire and
go check that out we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so let us speak of the other Democratic
candidates so the saddest story of the
day it is not the memorial for George HW
Bush because that's actually not sad
that's actually kind of and we'll talk
about it in a little while
it's kind of moving and wonderful in in
some way obviously his death is very sad
but that we talked about the saddest
stories that Michael avenatti ruled out
of 20/20 but and I gotta be honest with
you it's hard for me to do the show
today like it's it's been it's been very
brutal for me and I appreciate your
condolences I appreciate your thoughts
and prayers
Michael avenatti as you know was my
black horse pick for 20/20 he was he was
the person who was going to he's gonna
shock the world by being the anti-trump
and then he has released a statement
yesterday and I'm I don't know how I'm
gonna go on honestly he says after
consultation with my family and at that
request I've decided not to seek the
presidency of the United States in 2020
I do not make this decision lightly I
make it out of respect for my family but
for their concerns I would run so
nothing really as nice as a guy saying
he's not gonna run for president because
his children suck that's pretty that's
pretty great I love that he actually
just says it out loud if it weren't for
my family those jerks
I would definitely run but now they're
making me not run which is why I'm a
porn lawyer is that will continue to
represent store McDaniels and others
against Donald Trump in his cronies and
will not rest until Trump is removed
from office and our Republican it's
values are restored by the way this is
also called being a crappy lawyer so
when I hire a lawyer that lawyers job is
not to turn my case into a political
crusade against the person against whom
I am filing a lawsuit it's win the
lawsuit but according to avenatti he's
going to get Trump tossed from office I
mean I listen before we bid a fond adieu
to Michael avenatti it is important to
note that if not for Michael avenatti
Brett Kavanaugh might not be able to
Supreme Court so thank you to Michael
avenatti for that and he says I will
also continue with my nearly 20 years of
speaking truth to power and representing
those who need an advocate against the
powerful I remain concerned that the
Democratic Party will move toward
nominating an individual who might make
an exceptional president who has no
chance of actually beating Donald Trump
the party must immediately recognize
that many of the likely candidates are
not battle-tested and have no real
chance at winning will not prevail in
2020 without a fighter I remain hopeful
the party finds one
busta the the hidden actually tweet the
vast apart but he should have so in any
case he is out michael avenatti out and
a moment of silence for michael avenatti
who will go back to representing people
who who are receptacles of human fluids
for money Duval Patrick also says that
he's not going to announce for president
so this reduces the ranks of possible
Democratic hands that it's from one
hundred and fifty thousand two hundred
and eleven to one hundred fifty thousand
two hundred and nine so former
Massachusetts governor Patrick Duval is
set to announce he will not run for the
Democratic presidential nomination in
2020 according to multiple reports now
why is that interesting it's interesting
because Patrick is close friends with
Obama and there was a lot of speculation
that Duval Patrick was going to be
endorsed by President Obama is sort of
the Obama Nouveau he was going to be the
man of color running from a liberal
state who is going to sweep the nation
with a red states and blue states were
the United States routine and remember
Obama cribbed a lot of his 2008 language
directly from speeches by Duval Patrick
since of all Patrick is out well what
this suggests is that President Obama is
positioning himself behind someone else
why well Patrick apparently was worried
about being able to stand out in a
crowded primary says it's hard to see
how you even get noticed in such a big
broad field without being shrill
sensational or celebrity and I'm none of
those things and I'm never gonna be any
of those things well the answer would be
that he would get Obama support or
Michelle Obama's support who's immensely
popular she's already sold two million
copies of her memoir so he is out which
is which was fascinating there's been a
lot of talk over the past couple of days
that one of the reasons that he is out
is because Barack Obama is mobilizing
his team behind get ready for it
beta O'Rourke so bado who lost a close
Senate election to Ted Cruz in Texas and
the media tried to prop him up they
tried to make him the new thing he's a
talented politician no question it is
amazing how beta O'Rourke has been able
to escape the intersectional politics of
the left by paying homage to the
intersectional politics of the left now
bait overseas Kamala Harris and
Democratic primaries how does that go
who the hell knows because it is true
that a disproportionate number of
Democratic primary voters are black and
they tend to pretend to vote
disproportionately for black candidates
in Democratic primaries when available
so can beta O'Rourke overcome that
also who knows how this whole thing
breaks down because remember a lot of
the Democratic priority primaries in
these various states are not actually
winner-take-all
so you recall that in the Republican
primaries a lot of these states were
winner-take-all so Trump would win like
31 percent of the vote in South Carolina
and then he would take all of the
delegates and that's how he built up
this whopping delegate lead that allowed
him to win the nomination well a lot of
the Democratic primaries are not that
way a lot of those Democratic primaries
are proportional representation which
means that if you have eleven candidates
in a Democratic primary and each of them
are winning nine percent of the vote you
could go to the convention without an
obvious frontrunner and the super
delegate procedures that were just
trashed in order to sort of cater to
Bernie Sanders
all of those super-delegates are no
longer relevant so you could actually
see an enormous amount of chaos and
infighting from the Democrats in 2020
with 1 million candidates running
against each other barring the
possibility of a big name like Michelle
Obama tossing her hat in the ring and I
I'm not somebody who's going to
completely discount the idea that
Michelle runs you know I think that
there is a solid possibility that all of
this has been a head fake and the
Michelle Obama says listen for the good
of the country we need someone unifying
I'm in if she were to run it would be a
very very bad thing for president Trump
she does have a lot of popularity still
with the American public okay meanwhile
in other news that is you know I think
bad news the Weekly Standard is
apparently going to be shut down that is
the news from CNN and a bunch of other
outlets the Weekly Standard has been a
longtime
popular right-wing conservative magazine
it was it was largely seen as very much
in sort of the George W Bush mould on
foreign policy it was neoconservative as
very interventionist on foreign policy
according to CNN the fate of the Weekly
Standard a conservative magazine that
has staked out a position as a
publication on the right still critical
of President Trump is uncertain editor
in chief Steven Hayes told staff in a
series of phone calls on Tuesday
according to to people familiar with the
matter the magazine's precarious
position comes after its leadership
spent months searching for a buyer that
people told CNN and those people
explained that the weekly standards
leadership and butted heads with media
DC the current publisher of the magazine
and that the two parties had agreed to
allow Hayes to search for a new owner
however media DC recently informed the
Weekly standards leadership
but he was no longer interested in a
sale those people said instead the
chairman of media DC asked to meet with
Hayes and the basic assumption is that
the Washington Examiner which is owned
by the same parent company and is
starting a new news magazine which looks
quite good with Seth Mandel my friend
Seth Mantell as the editor over there
that they are going to pick up all of
these subscriptions that Weekly Standard
has and weekly standards will shut down
as a brand so there's been a lot of talk
in both right and left wing media about
whether this is reflective of the fact
that the weekly standard has been
overtly anti-trump throughout his
presidency and I think the answer is
sort of yes now that's not to suggest
that Seth and the new Washington
Examiner Magazine are gonna be Pro Trump
mega rah rah rah
Seth is a guy who did not vote for Trump
in 2016
his wife Bethenny did not vote for Trump
a bunch of these staffers bring on did
not vote for Trump in 2016 but there is
a difference between the Bill Kristol
brand of people who didn't vote for
Trump and have spent the last several
years tearing down anything from Christ
to do no matter how good it is and a
brand new people who are very skeptical
and critical of Trump but who are also
more than happy to accept the gains that
President Trump has provided to
conservatives and this manifests in a
couple of ways first of all I think that
the Republican base can take
conservatives can take criticism of
President Trump so long as those folks
know that the criticisms are stemming
from a place of conservatism and not
from mere ire that Trump is president
and it's not just from animus and the
way you can tell the difference is am i
criticizing Trump on the basis of policy
on the basis of what I think is
effective or my criticizing Trump
because I think the Trump himself is a
disgrace to the Republican Party and
republicanism and everything good for
Trump and good for conservatism is bad
for America now that is a real
distinction that's why people like Max
poot and Jennifer Rubin and Bill Kristol
have largely been criticized by folks on
the right including folks like me who
have said you guys have forgotten the
threat you've lost the thread of the
argument you can be critical of
President Trump when he does something
wrong but he is the president of the
United States and you can even be
critical of whether you think he's been
overall good for the Republican Party
but to ignore the benefits and to
pretend those benefits don't exist in to
downplay and denigrate those benefits is
not intellectually honest I think that's
been
a lot of the backlash to folks like
crystal now I don't think that applies
by the way to a huge number of the
staffers the Weekly Standard I think
there are a ton of fantastic writers
over at the Weekly Standard a lot of
great thinkers over the Weekly Standard
I'm friends with a lot of those folks I
subscribe to the Weekly Standard when I
was a teenager and so I'm sad if the
publication is shut down I'm really sad
to see that go I'd like to see someone
step in and save it if that's a
possibility but this does point out some
serious divisions inside the
conservative movement even in the
Trump's skeptical right as to what
exactly should happen with Trump
that's crystallized to around Bill
Kristol saying that he wants to find a
primary challenger for Trump I think by
the way that that's a terrible idea I
think trying to find a primary
challenger for President Trump at this
point in time barring some sort of
serious criminal activity that mandates
the sort of impeachment hearing I think
it's a mistake the reason I think it's a
mistake is because then you are forcing
the conservative constituency to choose
between loyalty to President Trump and
their vote in 2016 and to supposedly
higher principles and that's not really
a real choice cuz a lot of people think
that Trump has actually been a pretty
good vessel for a lot of those
principles but it makes for a good
fodder for the left will say well look
at here the here's a true con a true
conservative running against Trump and
only 115 percent of the vote and Trump
is ripping on that guy day and night
until the Republican Party has been lost
to conservatism I don't think that's
true and I think the providing cover for
that argument is an enormous enormous
mistake alrighty so let's get to a
couple of things that I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like today this video was just moving
and heartbreaking and inspiring Bob Dole
World War two hero paying homage to
another World War two hero George HW
Bush and it does show you the Solidarity
that exists in America among a
particular cadre of folks and I'm not
talking about people who ran for
president I'm talking about people who
served in the United States military
there used to be common institutions in
the United States those institutions
were churches and schools and the
military these were these were places
where we all shared the same mission Bob
Dole and George HW Bush really went at
it during their lives George HW Bush ran
against Bob Dole in 1980 for the
Republican nomination he was very
critical of Bob Dole they fought
throughout the 1970s here was Bob Dole
who is obviously very aged and he's
being helped to his feet to salute the
- of George HW Bush
I mean there's still solidarity behind
certain principles in America if we lose
that solidarity we would lose everything
it's an amazing amazing moment obviously
so there's not much more to say about it
than that
meanwhile in other things that I like
today so good on young America's
Foundation so young American Foundation
what a major victory for free speech
they've now settled a lawsuit they filed
against the University of California at
Berkeley the lawsuit was based on the
attempt by UC Berkeley to make yeah pay
for security fees when I went and I
spoke there the university will have to
pay you have 70 grand to reimburse
attorneys fees rescind the
unconstitutional high-profile speaker
policy rescind the viewpoint
discriminatory security policy and
abolish its hecklers veto so that
protesters will be barred from
conservative from blocking conservatives
from speaking according to the Daily
wire it took over a year for ya to
achieve that victory yeah F noted no
longer can UC Berkeley place a three
p.m. curfew on conservative speech no
longer can UC Berkeley ban
advertisements for Yap sponsored campus
lectures no longer can UC Berkeley
relegate conservative speakers to remote
or inconvenient lecture halls on campus
while giving leftist speakers access to
preferred locations the policy that
allowed Berkeley administrators to
charge conservative students 20 grand
for security for my event which is an
amount three times greater than the fee
charged to leftist to host Sonia
Sotomayor that policy is now gone Yap
and UC Berkeley agreed to a fee schedule
that treats all students equally almost
students are handling money or serving
alcohol at an event the security fee
will be zero this is a monster win for
ya and it should send a notice to
universities across the country that
have attempted to crackdown on free
speech by exercising the hecklers veto
okay time for some things that I hate so
let's talk about PETA PETA the People
for the Ethical Treatment of Animals
they've made a lot of media fodder in
the recent past for saying some of the
dumbest crap humanly possible they can
they compared eating chicken to a
Holocaust on your plate which makes
perfect sense if humans were delicious
and nutritious and also if the Nazis had
not slaughtered 6 million Jews in the
Holocaust including women and children
that would make perfect sense their
latest attempt to force us all to comply
with their vegan demands and by the way
your I am somebody who is actually
pretty warm
to the idea that as nutritional advances
are made that we should move toward
those nutritional advances that allow us
to treat animals better but PETA annoys
the living hell out of me Peter
tweeted out words matter and as our
understanding of social justice evolves
our language evolves along with it
here's how to remove specie ISM from
your daily conversations stop using anti
animal language instead of kill two
birds with one stone say feed two birds
with one scone yeah that's happening
instead of be the guinea pig be the test
tube instead of beat a dead horse feed a
fed horse which also seems by the way
like you're mistreating an animal just
instead of bringing home the bacon bring
home the bagels which is pretty Jewish
and they say take the bull by the horns
instead of that take the flour by the
thorns yeah that's definitely gonna cure
all the problems PETA is that we're
gonna start treating animals better
because we say bring home the bagels
instead of bring home the bacon because
when somebody said bring home the bacon
when I say bring home the bacon I
specifically am talking about physical
bacon I the Orthodox Jew you know but
but you know what here's the truth
this is basically meat and potatoes kind
of stuff and I'm not against changing
some of our euphemistic language or
idiomatic language after all there's
more than one way to skin a cat
so that's that's possible too also it is
worth noting as producer Sonia noted
before the program People for the
Ethical Treatment of Animals is sort of
fond of killing animals there's peace in
Huffington Post from 2017 by the
director of the no-kill Advocacy Center
talking about how many animals
PETA actually kills apparently in 2014
PETA killed 2324 of the 2626 animals it
acquired it had a 1% adoption rate in
2015 it killed another 1500 last year
fourteen hundred and forty two were put
to death their majority of the remainder
were taken to local pounds where they
were also killed so well done PETA just
doing the work that that I guess none of
the other animal killers will do okay
other things that I hate today and one
of the things that makes conversation
about difficult topics very very rough
is when people attribute bad motive to
certain folks without attributing
similar motive to other folks and is
particularly true on issues of race is
that every issue in which racism
racism is immediately called an example
of that today Ronald's right as a
professor of law at Wake univer Wake
Forest University as a piece of the New
York Times called yes jury selection is
as racist as you think now we have proof
so what exactly is the proof that jury
selection is racist well based on
statewide jury selection records our
jury sunshine project discovered the
prosecutors remove about 20% of African
Americans available in the jury pool
compared with about 10% of White's
defense attorneys seemingly in response
remove more of the white jurors 22% than
black jurors 10% left in the post judge
and prosecutor pool I love how they just
insert that phrase seemingly in response
there's no evidence that it seemingly in
response that it's like prosecutors say
you know what we're gonna remove black
jurors from the pool cuz a racist and
the defense jurors are like you know
what stop racism we're gonna dismiss
white jurors obviously what's happening
here is that both defense and
prosecutors are using using race as a
proxy for political viewpoints when it
comes to matters of crime that's what's
obviously happening here now is that
racism well it's what Thomas told word
called discrimination type 2 so Thomas
ol we've talked about some program
before the economists time is Sol it was
black obviously he has he has a book
called discrimination and disparities
and/or disparities and discrimination
and he posits a sort of thought model
when it comes to discrimination there
are a couple of different types of
discrimination there's discrimination
type one okay this is like this is open
discrimination type one is you
discriminating based on what sort of
food you want for dinner tonight that's
you're discriminating on the basis of
who you want to marry right that the
discrimination is just a choice then
there's discrimination type two which is
I hate members of a particular race or
think that members of a particular race
are lesser on the basis of biology that
would be racism or Jews our member of a
conspiracy because they're members of
the Jewish tribe right this is this sort
of thing is discrimination type two so I
misspoke earlier this this jury
selection stuff would be an example of
what so will cost discrimination one a
and this is using race as a proxy for
other factors in the absence of other
information so to take in a perfectly
valid example people on the Left use
affirmative action in this way they say
that in the absence of other information
if I look at a black person and a white
person I can assume the black person is
poor and had worse
educational background thus we should
give that person an advantage in college
admissions now in the absence of other
in the absence of other information that
might actually and that might not
actually be a terrible argument the
problem with affirmative action is we do
have that other information we can
gather that other information and
because of that it is discriminatory to
simply assume overriding the evidence
that a black person necessarily had a
worse life than a white person however
when it comes to jury selection and
peremptory challenges which are
challenges that are just issued based on
somebody basically now thinking that
you're going to vote with them in a in a
jury pool this is discrimination 1a
which is the same sort of discrimination
that is used by taxi drivers in New York
both black and white who have refused to
pick out passengers of different races
at the same rate because they are using
race as a proxy for criminal behavior
now is that racism or is that simply
using a form of discrimination in the
absence of better information and so in
the case of taxi says this is why ooh
BRR is really good because you can
actually have drivers know something
about the passengers before they pick
them up right you have a passenger
rating and you can tell whether they are
safe or not and as a passenger you
actually have to submit your ID to Ober
when you first get an uber account for
example this is why we need more
information not less information but to
a tribute jury selection to racism on
behalf of the prosecutors but not racism
on behalf of the defense is to ignore
the real issue when it comes to jury
selection which is people using race as
a proxy for political viewpoint and
instead suggest that it's just the
prosecutors hate black people which is
obviously not the case another example
of this Madame Schirmer has an article
over at the Atlantic in which he talked
about a judge named named far the guys
named Thomas Farr and he was nominated
for the federal bench and the Justice
Department identified far in attorney
for Jesse Helms the senator from North
Carolina who used a lot of race baiting
when he ran for office in 1984 in 1990
for example in 1984 he put out flyers
saying look how the Democrats are
registering so many black voters Remley
pretty obvious race baiting and race
racist activity the Justice Department
identified far an attorney for Helm's as
aiding the Holmes campaign effort to
keep black voters from the polls
particularly in 1984 and then far and
then far had defended Jerry
maps that were drawn with race as a
concern and basically what happened with
this nomination is that Senator Tim
Scott was notified about all of this and
so Scott sank the nomination senator
Scott in accordance with Jeff Flake also
sank the nomination but it wasn't just
them right Marco Rubio came forward he
said as I studied this more I have
serious questions about this this was
not good enough for Adam sir were over
at the Atlantic who says that the
problem is that Republicans are willing
to overlook racism unless it's Tim Scott
notifying them of such and so basically
he argues much has been said about the
diversity of the incoming class of
Democratic freshmen representatives and
about the corresponding whiteness of the
Republicans allegation until the
Republican Party is beholden to diverse
constituencies until it's based properly
regards attacks on the rights to vote as
attacks on democracy until it sees its
path of power and appealing to minority
voters rather than just enfranchising
them it will continue to produce more
time as far as them Tim Scott's except
for the fact that the Republican Party
was going to vote down one of the
president Trump's own nominees Jeff
Flake is a white guy in the Republican
Party Marco Rubio is Hispanic guy inside
the Republican Party all it took was a
couple of votes to kill Thomas FAR's
nomination and it was killed so this
argument doesn't actually follow
attributing far going down to Republican
racism his weird argument when's the
last time a Democratic nominee went down
because somebody in the Democratic
caucus objected to intersectionality
language from the Democratic nominee so
again this is not to say that there
isn't racism among certain Republicans
I'm sure there is and of course I know
there is but that is not the same thing
as suggesting that the Republican Party
is overtly racist because they listened
to Tim Scott very very strange argument
okay so we will be back here tomorrow
with all of the latest we're gonna be
broadcasting from Washington DC tomorrow
so we'll see you then I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing